je veux dire merci à des veline d'être
avec nous bonjour delphine prochain vous
êtes ravissante delphine mais
franchement vous êtes fraîche bien vous
allez bien vous avez l'air reposé merci
d'être avec nous vous faites quoi dans
la ville de fos et vous faites quoi dans
la vie des filles aide-soignante aide
soignante alors eh on pense à vous faire
vous travaillez en ce moment je ne
travaille pas en ce moment je pense à
mes collègues très fortement qui elle
est bon on pense à vos collègues on
pense à vous et on est très content de
pouvoir vous faire gagner peut-être ce
soir jusqu'à 50000 euros à partager en
plus avec la fondation des hôpitaux de
paris et de france et pour jouer avec
vous voilà c'est le sait
là j'ai pris pour le début voilà je vous
le savez j'avais camille lellouche hier
qui est une de mes comics préférés
aujourd'hui j'ai une de mes chanteuse
préférée c'est ma roue à l'autre qui est
avec nous aulas fall o la folle est avec
nous ça va ma marois sarrail sa superbe
merci en tout cas marois d'avoir accepté
de jouer pour la fondation des hôpitaux
de paris et de france marois et qu'il
faut faire un truc pour les associations
tout ça elle répond toujours présente
c'est pour ça que je te kiffe aussi ma
chérie un coeur énorme mais je voulais
dire marois alain acker énorme et elle a
dit tout de suite ouais je veux jouer je
veux participer et je veux essayer
d'aller gagner jusqu'à 50000 euros sa
maman moi c'est pas trop dur le
confinement un petit peu un petit peu
mais bon on est comme on est tous pareil
alors marois ma chérie est ce que tu
peux mettre au pot téléphone en paysage
on fait de la télé voilà vous avez vu on
est en direct eu le retour en paysage
merci ma chérie tu voi halal halal nous
fait une chantal ladesou la maroilles
encore de l'autre côté un merde
de l'autre côté c'est pas grave non
encore voilà là c'est celle là non là
c'est pas bon voilà là nous appellent ou
ping encore un petit tour et c'est bon
vasily dernier le dernier encore c'est
non on n'est pas bon il était alors là
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave c'est
quoi il faudra désactiver la rotation
tout ça ne bouge pas je vais passer chez
toi remets toi comme tu étais tout à
leur aise comme ça c'est parfait c'est
comme ça delphine et marois on va jouer
et vous allez jouer avec nous pour
gagner peut-être jusqu'à 50000 euros
delphine quelle boîte tu choisis tu fait
équipe avec marois alors attention
quelle boîte vous voulez mettre de côté
qui va être votre boîte pendant
toute la durée du jeu pour pouvoir
peut-être gagné 58 lots tout le monde
dit c'est l'heure des bois boîte tout le
monde et comme des fous allez c'est
parti
delphine sk welch courtois à 6 la sismar
ou est ce que tu es d'accord avec elle
fit je suis là c'est mon frère sur l'a6
en plus donc c'est parfait
et ben voilà tu étais hyper sur l'a6
l'a6 représenté par kelly v novelli ce
sera votre boîte les chéris attention on
va tout de suite éliminer les trois
premières boîtes et j'espère qu'on va
pas éliminer les sommes les plus
importantes puisque je vous rappelle que
voilà vous avez 50000 euros 10000euros
5000 euros 1000 euros 500 euros 100
euros 1 dinar tunisien et vous avez un
smartphone un casque audio une machine à
café des piles impôts pong 1,9 un tuba
une équerre attention les chéris marois
et delphine vous éliminer une première
boîte c'est parti
marois je te laisse choisir ok alors la
note
parce qu'il est entre les deux la note
pourra ça c'est un truc que tu aimes pas
que tu aimes pas le ch et le chiffre 9
non mais comme on entre le 6 et 9 du
coup comme on a pris six barrages et
2009 allez c'est parti on y va on
élimine la première boîte et marois et
delphine élimine la boîte numéro 9 et
c'est une boîte pas mal pour cette
première vous avez librement toutes
façons 500 euros vous éliminez la boîte
à 500 euros
marois et des filles delphine quelle
boîte élimine c'est parti alors j'ai lu
ni la saq l'a5 l'a5 l'a5 l'a5 c'est
isabelle morini bosc a failli jouer avec
nous isabelle mais qui viendra nous
rejoindre tout à l'heure attention la 5
pour cette deuxième boîte à on élimine
encore une somme on élimine 100 euros
attention pour l'instant vous avez
éliminé bon c'est les deux boîtes avec
les sommes les moins importantes
c'est rien gravats mais il faudrait
éliminer un petit peu du bleu la déchire
il faudrait éliminer un petit peu du
bleu marois des lives in quelle boîte
l'a4 l'a4 la boîte avec gilles verdez
attention la boîte numéro 4
marois c'est toi qui choisis la 4 way
bah moi pourquoi tu as choisi la caf oh
non non non non non on va dire si leur
fiche la paix raconte s'inquiète pas
pour l'instant
après trois boîtes et les ministres afin
qu'il ya cinq boîtes vous avez encore
les boîtes les plus importantes 50000 10
me il ya notre banquier merzoug
blanchard qui est avec nous qui va nous
faire une première proposition
bonsoir merzoug blanche l'arc et bien
sûr car celui-ci est trader un bond de
père en fils
voilà exactement merci comment ça va
bien je vous remercie allah écoute et je
vais très bien beaux jours à marwa que
j'adore et bon jeu
oui je vais bien là mais aujourd'hui je
suis bon ok bon bref alors qu'est ce que
je vous propose
je vous propose de vous acheter votre
boîte pour la modique somme de dix mille
dirhams c'est à dire mille euros 1000
euros pour la boire delphine delphine et
marwa 1000 euros tout de suite et vous
arrêter non elle n'est pas non plus
vous n'avez pas aimé la proposition du
charcutier traders merzouk blanche à
merzouga
merci vous revenez dans un instant en
tout cas merci merzouk de votre
proposition vous refuser la proposition
à milo attention on élimine trois autres
boîtes delphine et marois c'est parti on
élimine quelle boîte
moi j'aurais proposé l'a8 l'a8 à l'est
la ville aviv ce thème avec raymond
dessus attention vous avez toujours les
boîtes à cinquante mille à dix mille à
cinq mille et à 1000 euros
si vous nous rejoignez aux jo boiboite
de babar
à
ça me fait de la peine parce que vous
perdez le dinar tunisien
bonne nouvelle pour l'instant ça se
passe il y arrête très bien à wisches
est ce qu'on peut avoir une petite
musique s'il te plaît d'ambiance si vous
pouviez vous réveillez merci des chiens
les amours quelle boîte éliminé vous
maintenant
on a une à plein régime
ouais laquelle la marque
la 15 attend avec notre ami jimmy
mohamed notre docteur dhimmi mois mais
les cherry pour l'instant ça se passe
plutôt très très bien vous avez éliminé
quatre boîtes et vous avez toujours les
quatre sommes les plus importants on
joue pour delphine une téléspectatrice
une aide soignante en plus on embrasse
tous les aides soignants sud on regarde
on leur fait d'énormes bijoux et aux
joues pour les hôpitaux de paris et
hôpitaux de france
qui a choisi la 15
des liquides sétois delphine oui
delphine
j'aime bien televid le caire ceux-là on
est pas mal du tout on n'est pas mal du
tout pour l'instant les iris et enfin
deuxième tour de piste très très bon
allez on élimine une troisième boîte et
après on va avoir
l'appel de notre charcutier traiteur
merzoug blanchard c'est parti moi je
propose la deux l'a2 pas les révéler ses
parts valérie bénaïm allez on élimine la
deux il nous reste encore toutes les
boîtes les plus importantes si vous nous
rejoignez chez vous on est en direct
c'est ce soir c'est baba seller boiboite
de baba
[Musique]
et
effet
ouais était au bout à tony cavet dans
les boîtes ou quoi parce que moi je ne
sais pas ce qu'il ya dans les bois vous
éliminez à 9
aulas est là elle a là vous avez fait un
tir groupé un sans faute sur ces trois
boîtes exceptionnelle pour l'instant
marois l'aude et delphine pour l'instant
ça se passe très très bien et nos
banques et un sert à vous faire une
belle proposition
merzouk blanchard charcutier traiteur
merci merci d'être là
déjà vous intérieur en difficulté m t
bank
il reste la coordination eau people1
vitesse où vous allez bref des films à
petit delphine emma bell maroilles hood
dans le baby foot il faut prendre ce
qu'on vous donne des fois pour moi je
vous rachète ces voix là vous racheter
la boîte à combien alors je rachète la
boîte pour la modique somme de 2011 qui
déjà une bonne somme dire de leur humeur
ou emilie moreland personnel pour les
autres il vous reste encore 50 mille dix
mille 5000 emile et vont être encore
cinq boîtes pâtes et riz
qu'est ce qu'on en a d'autres qui le
barça a mis leur fils
je rends service aujourd'hui détritus
refuse également oui oui eh bien ils
refusent la proposition de mr sous
plancha les cherry on élimine une
nouvelle boîte avec marois et delphine
allez c'est parti
il nous reste plus que
3 4 9 boîte avec la vôtre c'est parti
moi je suis là où je réponds moi
j'aurais dit la douce pas pris
choisissant delphine choisi après marois
choisira la tienne l'infinitude ils
atteignent rooney 12 blague
jean luc lemoine
l'adjoint du conte en mars jean luc
lemoine
qu'y at-il dans la boîte numéro 2
rappelle qu'il reste encore 50 mille dix
mille 5000 et lille
les chéris
marois qui voulait la 11 non gelée à 12
mois cf c'est quelqu'un tous les lacs
delphine on perdit mello
à 10000 euros mais il reste encore les
50 mais il reste encore les seins mais
il reste encore les 1000 euros a laissé
rien on va chercher les 50000 euros
l'aller fihri allez on y va
marc watts élimine quelle boîte ben du
coup la 11 il reste encore les 50000
euros les chérir est encore les cinq
minutes on a éliminé une grosse boîte
mais il en reste encore de très très
bien aller là ont tout à l'heure vous
avez fait un tour de piste incroyable
là ça démarre un petit peu plus mal mais
on va s'en sortir chaussures
marouane je voulais la rose depuis le
début
non content mais là c'était surtout les
lances les bad est il avait raison ben
on avait un casque audio vous perdez
macalou d'être écouté leschi rien on
n'est pas né quand même on est quand
même pas mal du tout pour le moment il
nous reste cinquante mille euros 5000
euros 1000 euros le smartphone la
machine à café les piles allez on
enchaîne avec une nouvelle boîte et
après on aura l'appel de mer ou
blanchard delphine et marois je me suis
dit là 13
la préfet la frêchie la corrèze
avec doc gynéco
encore une forte chance moi et je n'ai
donc pas à wes est pas en plus car
souvent payé une surcôte et lui
les chérir est encore les 50000 euros
les 5000 les 1000 ils portent chance doc
gynéco d'habitude marois la vie sud one
et bah ça continue c'est magique il vous
reste encore six boîtes dont la boîte à
50000 la boîte à 5000 la boîte à 1000 et
les séries on va laisser vous appelez
bus que dans un instant on aura la
proposition de merzoug blanchard la mer
vous que sa proposition à la rive dans
deux minutes a tout de suite
merci à delphine aide soignante qui joue
avec nous pour les boîtes et elle espère
repartir avec 50000 euros à partager
pour la fondation des hôpitaux de paris
et hôpitaux de france les chéris je sais
que vous adorez ce moment ed boiboite
tous les soirs et là vous avez fait un
parcours qui est très très bon pour
l'instant on va revoir les sommes les
cherry on va voir ce qui reste il vous
reste la boîte à 50000 la boîte à 5000
la boîte à 1000 et vous reste quand même
le smartphone les piles et le tuba pour
dire c'est du 50 50
on a 50 % de très belles sommes et 50%
de cadeaux voilà on aimerait éviter
merci mme blanchard je pense qu'il lui
dans une proposition est une belle
proposition à mme marois et a défini
hier
on rappelle que le candidat et les
hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de france
sont repartis avec 1500 euros chacun là
il reste quand même la boîte à 50000 la
boîte à 5000 la boîte annie donc mr ou
mme blanchard charcutier trader on
espère une belle proposition va écouter
après avoir vu avec tous mes banquiers
de l'atp mb banques
oui je vous propose donnez-vous bien île
de sable somme de 3000 euros pour
acheter votre boîte soit 2000 euros pour
acheter la boîte
lassé des langues et marois qui prennent
la décision
moi je n'ai non non non non si vous y
croyez il reste encore la boîte à
cinquante mille à cinq mille ya mille tu
leur propose trois mille euros
il faut que tu revois un tu reviennes
merzouki pour l'instant tu va refaire de
la charcuterie en charcutier traders
nature birtouta leur motion
allez on est reparti on élimine trois
autres boîtes les chéris c'est parti
imaginez est ce que je peux te demander
je fais un petit récap des boîtes rondes
a ouverte
ces réunions sont un peu perdus alors il
te reste en tout cas il te reste la rue
d'la droit l'a14 l'a7 et l'a10 la une la
3 l'a14 l'a7 et l'a10 et vous avez la
boîte si ce que vous avez mises de côté
vous pouvez changer à tout moment aussi
si vous voulez ok d'accord elle ce poème
dire j'ouvre l'a61 bon on l'éliminé
voilà mais comme vous voulez tant envers
la vie d'anne briand je te laisse aller
la fête
la sete ouais là cet c'est notre jean
michel maire allez pour l'instant on
n'est pas mal j'espère qu'on va éliminer
ou les piles ou le tuba ou le smartphone
les chéris ça se passe très bien on
élimine le tuba le tuba allez on
enchaîne avec une autre boîte et on
élimine le smartphone et les piles et là
on sera au top
allez on y va il vaut 1 0 et 14
l'a3 l'a10 et où la lune moi j'aurais
dit la caf à la 14 symbolisée par sophie
cost alors il a 14 14
[Musique]
eroglu
c'est relou parce que ça peut servir
vous perdez des piles
attention l'entrée aux asiles votre
troisième boîte votre troisième bois
klich allez on en délit minutes d une
autre et après il restera plus que trois
boîtes
franchement ça va déjà on est bien sorti
au pire vous avez un smartphone c'est
déjà pas mal à smart pots de chambre ou
un smartphone qu'on nous sommes ra voilà
d'offrir à la la la voilà la équivalent
en blessant d'autres hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux du caire alors est ce la fait
je pensais à la 7
on a alors là c'est que vous l'avez déjà
éliminé il vous reste l'a3 l'a10 et l'a6
que vous avez déjà mises de côté moi
j'aurais dit la une la lune aller non
non non non martèle qu'il t'a dit la foi
ouais je vais sur l'a31 dix chalets la
suite à pas matthieu delormeau la 3
allez on va voir ce qu'on élimine
j'espère qu'on n'élimine pas les 50000
les 5000 ou les mille on va illuminer le
smartphone
[Musique]
les chéris j'ai pas des bonnes nouvelles
vous venez d'éliminer la boîte à 5000 au
donc là là je vous reste la boîte à 1000
la boîte à 50 milles et le smartphone
une chance sur trois d'avoir les 58
euros ou bien on pouvait retrouver avec
le smartphone ou avec 1000 euros ce qui
est moins que ce que vous a proposé pour
l'instant notre banc tous merzoug
blanchard avant que tu fasses ta
proposition je te rappelle qu' encore
les cinq autres mises d'accord
donc attention à toi merci mon merzouk
d'être là merzouk blandine donne à
chaque charcutier traiteur pas de menace
n'inquiète pas je ne me lasserai jamais
tu sais que je t'aime
alors voilà je j'ai envie de citer grand
écrivain qui dit grand écrivain qui
disaient oh la folle au la folle elle s
est parti avec nicolas seube et la mine
propose quatre mille euros madame
4les les laudes 4000 euros 4000 euros
les chéris moi je peux rien vous dire
c'est une très belle somme ça ferait
2000 euros tout de suite pour delvin et
2000 euros pour les hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france ou bien vous me dites
on prend ces deux mille euros tout de
suite qui correspond j'aurais genre vous
auriez pu proposer un peu plus
d'ailleurs parce qu'il reste encore la
boîte à 50 mille attentions le bout des
seins nus des invraisemblances et
excusez moi oui je sais pas ce que je
connais votre cousin bouder voilà à
voile à delphine tel fidh
non je refuse
vous refusez studieuse que refuse 11 est
joyeuse
oui c'est pas mal moins croyants votre
bonne étoile
les chéris oui on aura une dernière
intervention de ben azzouz blanchard
dans un instant allez les chéris on y
croit il reste trois boîtes égal et
50000 euros on va aller les chercher ils
vont est la boîte 10 la boîte une et
vous avez toujours votre boîte 6 que
vous avez mis de côté quelle boîte vous
éliminez maintenant avant qu'il ne vous
reste plus que les deux boîtes
allez moi je dirais la une moi si on est
on est les mines la hume
on élimine 1,6 et les 50000 euros là
dedans
on aura fait une mauvaise affaire mais
il nous reste pas toujours les mulots
les chéris
aux éliminés le smartphone alors
attention il vous reste il vous reste
maintenant deux boîtes l'a10 et l'a6 il
ya une boîte à 1000 euros
une boîte à 50 millions
les chéris vous allez avoir une dernière
proposition de notre banquier fin de
notre charcutier traders mais rose ou
blanche a laissé
quel est votre proposition merzouk je
vous propose une somme astronomique un
parce que là on est en astronomie
exactement 8000 euros et c'est pas où on
vous paye tout de suite c'est pas à tous
les jours on vous fait galérer venant
8000 euros cage 4000 pour vous catherine
pour les hôpitaux de paris delphine et
marois je voulais c'est réfléchir un
petit peu il vous reste deux boîtes une
boîte à 50000 une boîte à 1000 merzouk
blanchard notre charcutier traiteur vous
propose huit mille euros tout de suite
soit vous prenez les 8000 euros
au risque de perdre des 50 minoru mais
aussi avec la possibilité peut-être de
gagner beaucoup plus que 1000 euros ou
bien vous me dites non mais oui en syrie
au continue et on va aller chercher les
cinq ans qui dort madame est joueuse
il vous reste deux boîtes l'a6 et l'a10
l'a6 est les deux côtés c'est votre
boîte depuis le début le banquier vous a
proposé huit mille euros
marois
et delphine
ce qui ferait 4000 euros pour les la
fondation des hôpitaux de paris et 4000
euros tout de suite pour vous delphi
- hier moi aussi je refuse je veux
continuer ce tir il vous refuser la
proposition de notre charcutier trader
du jamais vu
c'est une honte je la donne merci merci
plancha il vous reste de bouaké chérif
il vous reste la boîte 6
et la boîte 10 et vous le savez
à ce moment du jeu
je vous pose une question est ce que
vous choisissez d'échanger votre boîte
ou est-ce que vous continuez
avec votre boîte ans toutes les deux les
tessons de 6 donc je pense que ce serait
cool de garder le suit sans être au fond
qu'est-ce qui veut bien figurer
non mais il faut arrêter nous appelez là
monsieur qu'est ce que tu veux dis moi
tu fais à manger à prix d'émission
oui j'ai eu projets ou propositions non
mais qu'on m'a proposé ce dont on a déjà
fait plein j'ai passé au crible rappeler
que sous le 10 mois moi je décroche on
m'appelle je décroche lui tu nous
appelles crawl à toulouse a saoulé tu
nous appelles qu'au nom mais ce que je
vous propose c'est un pan de votre boîte
vous repartez avec l'album de maroilles
ou dramatique à des séries si vous nous
rejoignez qu'est ce que tu veux tu peux
tu as un truc à nous dire merci
sinon
merzouk caprica nous dire sinon non
merci alors attendez ce que j'ai un truc
à vous dire non la réponse est non merci
nous appeler juste comme ça de dire les
chéris aller le le moment est grave
il y a
mille euros dans une boîte
cinquante mille euros aux nôtres
si dans la boîte numéro 6
il ya les 1000 euros
ce sera 500 euros pour delphine et 500
euros pour moi pour les hôpitaux de
france
les autres packs ce qui est déjà voilà
c'est quand même une belle somme on sera
content quoi qu'il arrive
mais peut-être que dans la boîte numéro
6 il y avait cinquante mille euros
pourquoi vous avez choisi la boîte
ignore aussi ce n'est pas c'est quoi le
6 pour vous delphine j'ai mon grand
garçon qui est né le 6 novembre
d'accord il a quel âge aujourd'hui 22
cents pour lui faire un gros bisou il
s'appelle comment thomas marois pourquoi
tu voulais l'axé histoire j'ai pas j'ai
toujours aimé ce chiffre je ne sais pas
pourquoi aucune idée va m'en demander
plus mais le cij pas ça m'inspire et bah
écoute moi ça fait des années que je
dois aller sur m6 chaque fois resté sur
sa vie je suis bien ici tu vois ainsi
qu'une rejoins moi je vous aurais
conseillé l'a vite puisque c'est ma chef
de choeur ma famille
malheureusement la vie de vous l'avez
déjà les séries allez on a pris la
décision
on est d'accord on garde la six on
élimine la 10 je vous pose une dernière
fois la question après terminée
non je le regarde je garde la syrie
marois était d'accord aussi pour garder
la city
je vais donc
ouvrir
et avec tout le monde
la gueule c'est rien c'est la téloche
d'ouvrir directement la boîte numéro 6
[Musique]
delphine
vous êtes aide soignante vous habitez ou
des films
à solesmes dans le nord dans le nord
vous êtes marié fiancée au pétrole ce
qui venant mais au fond nous lâcher la
main tenant wild tu veux oui alors l'atp
banque vous propose non pas unique mais
commence et finit cette limite euros est
c'est fini c'est fini
elle en veut pas je crois on est
d'accord delphine et marne
sans voix dit que je vous fais chier ou
on n'en veut pas merzouk delvin
bonjour pour les hôpitaux de paris
et hôpitaux de france
[Musique]
dans cette boîte je vais l'ouvrir
je vais regarder d'abord
moi même ce qu'il ya dans la boîte
shi
[Musique]
inquiète de tout à le faire normalement
espère ap doigts
va voir
et delphine il est 19 heures 55
[Musique]
je sais à présent ce qu'il y a dans la
boîte numéro 6
depuis le début vous avez choisi cette
boîte vous nous avez dit que le 6 c'est
un chiffre important puisque votre fils
est né le 6 novembre
delphine vous avez fait un pari ou de
roof depuis le début c'est vrai que vous
enchaînez voilà vous avez tout éliminer
tout ce côté là d'abord après on a eu un
petit peu peur sur les 10000 euros
mais la boîte numéro 6 depuis le début
elle vous porte chance
et c'est vrai que c'est votre boîte de
prédilection je vous ai proposé et un
instant d'échanger les boîtes notre
banquier vient nous rappeler est de vous
proposer dix mille euros d'infini et
marwa 10000 euros
dix mille euros ce sera étaient 5000
euros au goût delphine et 5000 euros
pour la fondation des hôpitaux de paris
et de france
marois j'avais refusé les 10000 euros
delphine aussi vous avez vous convaincu
que dans cette boîte là il y a la somme
de 50000 euros
waouh est-ce que tu as un petit truc à
nous dire avant que j'ouvre la boîte et
que je vous montre qu'il ya dedans un
petit truc à vous de lire ouais y'a rien
à voir je dis ce que je te dis ce que tu
veux ok bayard que même moi ben moi
j'aime mais moi j'ai besoin de moi j'ai
belote décompresser suppôts de la voile
à ses pieds en titre vendredi dernier
cas qui s'appelle ça va aller elle est
choquée par le confinement c'est super
cool et surtout s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît restez chez
vous vraiment vraiment delphine en tant
qu'aide soignante est ce que tu as un
message à nous faire passer bas juste ce
que l'on répète ma foi semaine qui
commence et quand même à diminuer de le
rester chez soi c'est parfois difficile
mais il faut il faut rester chez soi
absolument marois sa voiture un petit
apéritif
ouais t'es au bout de ta vie pour
décompresser mais j'ai dû mettre au
suspense en fait d'alcool et les chérit
principal à l'arrêt la poule a les
chéris je suis obligé maintenant de vous
dire si
à
dans cette poule
minoru 50000 euros je vais vous dire moi
si j'avais été à votre place je vous
jure que c'est vrai j'aurais pris direct
les 10000 euros du bon pied
j' aurais pris direct parce que c'est
vrai qu'un tel garde contre 50 mille et
mille euros j'aurais pris lé dinh il
sort et fait c'est un mille euros je
suis sûre kalfin en a besoin
et mine de rien on en a besoin pour la
fondation des hôpitaux de paris les
hôpitaux de france mais vous avez choisi
de garder la boîte
la boîte à combien la boîte à 1000 euros
ou la boîte à 50 milles au juge je
voudrais vous dire un truc les filles
même si ces 1000 euros giuly c'est quand
même une très très belle soes
elle y ait accord donc on sera content
quoi qu'il arrive je voulais vous lire
on a été au bout du truc voilà on a on
ya cru on a gardé la boîte à 50 minutes
jusqu'à la fin peut-être que la boîte à
50000 c'était géraldine maillet et le
numéro 10 la seule chose que j'ai à vous
dire les filles
c'est que regarder les boîtes bavois les
plus grandes salles
est-ce qu'on peut marquer 50000 euros
dans cette petite boîte
oui delphine et marois a laissé le
moment delphine
puis vous allez pouvoir
[Musique]
partager avec les hôpitaux de paris est
empli de france la fondation pour
laquelle on a donné déjà 21500 euros
hier on a fait gagner 3000 euros encore
il ya nabila qui avait donné encore dix
mille euros en plus des 21500 euros
qu'on a on a déjà donné
on avait gagné on avait fait gagner dix
mille euros c'est avec qui veut gagner
des milliers c'est bien sûr très très
important pour nous parce que vraiment
ils en ont besoin et commandement de cet
argent et chaque jour on fera gagner une
somme aux hôpitaux de paris et de france
allait delphine joly
delphine et marois
grâce à vous
les hôpitaux de paris et de france
on gagner
[Musique]
oui
vous lirez dans un instant les schémas
je suis qu elle on est en direct avec
delphine et aides soignantes delphine
qui est avec sa famille qui l'a rejoint
delphine qui joue au bois boîte avec
nous et qui joue avec ma roue à l'autre
qui nous fait l'honneur d'être avec nous
de jouer avec nous ce soir marois qui
est toujours là pour aider les
associations qui a un amour de fiqh un
talent exceptionnel en plus et qu'on
kiffe de roof aller voir son nouveau
titre la voilà qu'elle a fait parce que
marwa même quand on écoute ses chansons
ça nous fait du bien on se sent mieux
voilà ma boîte un sourire exceptionnel
suite les neuf et embrasse pour ta
famille et tu dis à ton mari que je vais
le prendre ce soir à la halle appelé
d'accord ce soir chéri chéri et delphine
et marois il se passe un truc de fou
joie sur les réseaux c'est la faune
puisque on joue pour delle cime et pour
les hôpitaux de paris et hôpitaux de
france la fondation hôpitaux de paris
hôpitaux de france
depuis le début de l'aventuré on a donné
21500 euros à la fondation des hôpitaux
de paris
il reste
deux boîtes une boîte à 50000 une boîte
à 1000 euros pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent on est bien sûr en direct il
y avait notre charcutier trader bien sûr
les résout blanchard qui vous a proposé
dix mille euros tout de suite vous avez
dit non on a pris la 6 depuis le début
on veut l'a6 on se battra pour la 6 on
croit en la 6 et on va aller au bout et
classicisme
je sais maintenant ce qu'il ya dans la 6
est ce que dans la 6ème îlots où est ce
que dans la cia ce lundi hier il ya
cinquante mille on sait sur qui a passé
environ les après cinquante mille euros
au milan vous êtes avec vos fils comme
ils s'appellent vos deux fils la dette
une demain et lech tomasz à maroilles
avec des cacahuètes à et ça c'est le
troisième petit fils c'est le plus grand
comment il s'appelle ces votes c'est
votre conjoint comme ils s'appellent
c'est l'instant vincent je te fais un
gros bisou vincent et j'aime beaucoup
cette petite barre elle est bien là et
très bien toute la famille s'est réunie
delphine qui est aide soignante delphine
sylla les 1000 euros je voudrais dire à
toute la famille il faudra console et
maman ce soir et lui dire qu'elle a
quand même gagné 500 euros étaient pas
prêts à accepter c'était quand même pas
prévu aujourd'hui delphi il ne restait
pas prêts aujourd'hui que de gagner 500
euros et maroilles aura fait gagner 500
euros aux hôpitaux de paris à la
fondation des hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux
de france
les chéris allez je vous ai trop fait
attendre je sais que vous me détestez
non
s'il bat si massifs chez vous surtout
quand je vais vous montrer ce qu'il a
dans la boîte vous allez encore on peut
détester parce que dans la boîte dans la
boîte que vous avez choisi
delphine aide soignante
c'est quoi votre conjoint dans la ligne
[Musique]
palestine il travaille à l'usiné
d'accord il va très bien
[Musique]
les chiens
oubli
marois l'aude
on te remercie ce soir
quoi qu'il arrive
et les chéris y en a beaucoup moins être
des fûts beaucoup qui vont être déçus
parce que comme delphine et marwa ils
n'ont pas pu participer au jeu des bois
boîte ce soir delphine et toute sa
famille
vous repartez ce soir
avec
oui
[Musique]
et 25 millions les hôpitaux de paris
delphine cinq cobayes 5000 euros pour
toi ma fille et pour ta famille tes
heureusement delvin s'est tous fait des
grands bisous jeu franchement ça fait
tellement plaisir de vous amener du
bonheur comme ça voilà on m'a dit que
votre conjoint travaille à l'usiné vous
est aide soignante c'est un gros moment
de télé qu'on a enfin mis presque
vingt-cinq mille euros pendant le
continent où peut remercier marois
laudun qualité exceptionnelle paroisse
ah s'il était formidable là si tu nous
as néo pro choix pour la marche et 25000
euros la fondation des hôpitaux de
varier de france delphine si on pleure
depping qu'est ce que tu vas faire avec
les 25000 euros
je vais déjà faire une grosse fête quand
tout ça sera fini j'espère que tu
m'appelleras quand même facetime pour
faire participer les marchés riches ne
souhaite plein de bonheur tu gagnes
25000 euros pour toi et ta famille
j'espère que ce soir vous allez pouvoir
fêter sans sont restés bien chez vous
rester confiné j'espère vous allez
passer une bonne nuit grâce à à nous
grâce à à toutes les équipes voilà ton
préparer ces jeux et c'est une somme
énorme 25 millions joie hier les réseaux
sociaux c'est la folie elle vient de
gagner deux fines 25000 euros vous ne
rêvez pas jusqu'au mardi 25 mai l'euro à
delphine les médias vincent ce qui veut
dire après que voulait dire un truc les
garçons ouais merci merci merci merci et
maroilles rhodia son clip qui la regarde
et maman voir garder ma roue on va
regarder ton petit clip de ce monde et
où vous allez
vous êtes
ce nba et
ma belle
les
le perdu 10 heures
m
ça va aller marois l'autre qui nous
amène du sourire qui nous amène du
soleil qui nous amène du kif été amenés
25000 euros pour la fondation des
hôpitaux de paris et de france est elle
finie
25000 euros pour toi et le chien le
chien qui est magnifique ça s'est perdu
et les chéris je vous dis juste qu'un
seul truc qui fait et franchement vous
donner du bonheur je vous jure que ça va
égayer la soirée je vais qui fait ce
soir en étant confiné je vais penser à
vous et je vais me direz bon au moins on
n'a fait que des heureux ce soir
et ça c'est pour ça que je fais ce
métier et pour des moments comme ça avec
vous voilà je vous le dis franchement
merci et cherchent non merci à toi merci
les amours franchement je vous dis je
suis ému et franchement ça 25000 os et
les dents
merci ni chéri merci marois est énorme
sur 15 boîte ils ont trouvé les 25000
euros merci les chéris d'avoir été avec
nous